1989. China is at the top of the agenda
of the U.S Congress that was the message
delivered during a prime time hearing
featuring a highly produced video
showing what the U.S says is China's
history of human rights violations
innocent citizens were killed this was
the inaugural city of the newly formed
house select committee on China we may
call this
a strategic competition but it's not a
polite tennis match this is an
existential struggle over what life will
look like in the 21st century and the
most fundamental freedoms are at stake
the panel was created soon after
Republicans took control of the house in
January the committee's top Democrat
made clear his party was also fully on
board the goal of the CCP has become
clear to displace U.S and other
competitors especially in tomorrow's
strategic Industries as chairman she
himself recently said quote the East is
rising while the West is declining a
series of recent disputes between the
U.S and China have grown in intensity
straining relations between the world's
two biggest economies now U.S lawmakers
are taking aim at Tick Tock the
chinese-owned social media platform used
by 100 million Americans the house
Foreign Affairs committee is considering
a measure that would Grant the White
House house powers to ban Tick Tock from
the U.S Tick Tock is a modern day Trojan
Horse of the CCP used to surveil and
exploit Americans personal information
on Monday the White House ordered
Tick-Tock be removed from all U.S
federal government devices despite tick
tock's assurances that all U.S users
data is stored within the United States
a Chinese foreign Ministry spokesperson
said Tuesday the U.S is targeting
Tick-Tock due to its popularity in the
American Marketplace
and in another separate but parallel
action the house Financial Services
committee on Tuesday Advanced no fewer
than seven bills either opposing China
or supporting Taiwan this recent Spate
of anti-china actions from Washington
comes at a time of escalating tensions
that now are even less likely to ease
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington